-It's an "SNL" week. We're
in the back half of the week
so you're getting closer to it
This is your
fourth time hosting.
-Fourth time.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You flexed your live muscles a
different way earlier this year.
You did that live "All in th
Family," which was fantastic
-Oh, thank you. Thank you.
-And was that a different
kind of live pressure than "SNL"
or was it similar for you?
-You know, live, generally
I find a little bit daunting
-Yeah.
-You know?
But I think that's part
of the, you know, attraction
-Yeah.
-Get the blood up.
-You had a --
There was a long --
[ Laughter ]
There was a long gap between
your second and third "SNL."
I think it was basically,
like, '92 to '14,
and now you're repeating i
pretty soon after.
Does that mean
you're digging it?
It's good to be back?
-Oh, it's great to be back
I was supposed to do one in '97,
but I had some, uh, issues
I won't get into, and...
Yeah, I was down in Costa Ric-
It doesn't matter.
Anyway, uh...
-There was probably,
like, weather.
It was your flight and weather
Probably something like that
-That kind of thing.
And, so, that was '97.
So I would have had
the five-year thing
where you get the jacket.
-Yeah.
-But that will have to wait.
-Yeah, that will be
in the future.
You'll appreciate it more.
You know, you're wiser.
-Oh, yeah.
-See, you're a --
you're a laid-back guy.
You live in Maui, not L.A.
I think that must be helpful
What brought you to living there
in the first place?
-Maui?
-Yeah.
-Well, I ran into this fella
named Willie Nelson.
And, uh, we had a little sesh.
You know? Hung out.
You know? Reason together.
And -- And he says to me
at the end of our conversation
he says, "hey, man, you know
I have -- I live --
I have a place on Maui.
If you're ever there and
you want to come hang out,
you're welcome to."
I was like, "Yeah, I think
I'll do that. That's cool.
And so that's it.
-Wow.
-Willie brought us over.
-So, the first time you
were there at Willie's place
did you know right away, "Oh
this is where I want to be"?
-You know what it was?
Uh, yes. That is what it was
[ Laughter ]
-I can't believe
it has been ten years
since the first "Zombieland.
It feels very recent to me
'cause the film seems --
You know, it's a lot of people
that have obviously stuck around
like Jesse and Emma Stone an
Abigail Breslin and yourself
Did it feel weird
that it was ten years later?
Or did it feel like you guys
were just getting the gang
back together?
-To tell you the truth, Seth
felt like no time
had passed at all.
-Yeah.
Is that, though, in general,
how you feel about things?
-That's generally -- Yeah.
Yeah. It's just, like,
the weirdest continuum.
Fred gets me on this. Yeah
Yeah, I can just tell the way --
Just your knowledge
of art and Monet.
-Yeah, just, like, lock in -
Multiple timelines at once
-Right.
I mean, Monet's out there
telling them to turn --
So, anyway...
-You get to -- You guys --
Not to give too much away,
you end up at Graceland
in the film, and you're --
An Elvis Presley impersonation
you did was what convinced you
to get into acting, I've heard
Is that true?
-[ As Elvis ]
"Well, uh, actually, yeah.
Yeah, yeah."
-I mean, who can turn that down?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was it fun to put the suit on?
-You know, it was kind of fun.
I got to say, it made me -
It just --
As I walked around,
I felt like The King.
-Yeah.
-For a little while.
-Was this a thing
when you did growing up --
At what age were you doing Elvis
in a way that was
delighting an audience?
-Yeah. I was in high school,
and, you know,
I used to do a little imitatio
for the guys
on the football bus.
And so some of the guys were i
the library, and they're, like
trying to get me to do --
"Do your Elvis."
"Can't do it in here, man.
There's a lot of people
in here."
"Just do it.
You can do it quiet."
"No, I can't do it quiet.
I don't know how to..."
Well, anyway,
I don't know if it was there -
You know, somehow
they prevailed on me
or just my inner performer
came out.
And I started singing it, yo
know, kind of quiet at first
♪♪ Well, bless my soul,
what's wrong with me? ♪♪
-Yeah, that's very good.
-You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh. Thank you very much.
And, you know, it gets --
The song, you know,
kind of elevates.
♪♪ My heart beats so,
it scares me to death ♪♪
And then I hopped up
on the table,
and then everybody
was gathered around clapping
and then at the very end of it
they seemed to be --
They seemed to like it,
and this gal Robin Rogers
came up to me, and she said,
"I'm vice president
of the drama club.
Would you like to come
try out for a play?"
-Really?
-I said, "You know what?
Robin Rogers wants me
to try out for a play.
I'll try out for a play."
-And that's -- So she always
scouted in the library.
That's the first time
it paid off.
You -- I read a story
that you told recently
in an interview
that blew my mind.
That you went to dinner
with Jesse Ventura,
who was a wrestler and
then the governor of Minnesota
And that was the -- That
used to be the craziest thing,
is that a pro wrestler was
then the governor of a state
-Right.
-Back in quainter times.
-Yeah.
-But you were friends with him
Yes?
-Yeah.
-And then in 2004, you went ou
to dinner with Donald Trump.
-2002.
Donald Trump and Melania.
Oh, right, because Donald Trum
wanted him, Jesse,
to be his running mate
for the Democratic primary
in 2004.
-That's true.
-What was that dinner like
-Um...
[ Clears throat ]
Ohh...
It -- It was
a little bit tedious.
I'll be honest.
-Yeah.
-And no disrespect to our
current incumbent, but, uh..
Uh, yeah, I had to just
walk out after a while.
You know, when the guy's
just talky, talky, talky..
-He's -- Yeah. So, of
the four of you at the table
what percentage of the talking
would you think he did?
-He did about 98.
[ Laughter ]
Melania did about a .01.
And, you know,
I think I got maybe 1%.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But part of it, we included
"Can I -- Can you
excuse me for a moment?"
And I had to walk out
and fire one out just to..
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good advice. Good advice
for all of us in the moment.
If you can find a moment
to step away and fire one up
that'll help you through thi
tough, turbulent political time.
I can't wait for Saturday to
see you back out there again
Thanks so much for being here.
-Thank you, Seth. Pleasure
-Woody Harrelson, everybody.